You may be thinking,
life cycles are really important.
However this section,
is on persisting and recovering data.
Trust me, I just want to get us
coding again. However,
these things are closely linked
and they're easy to get wrong
if you don't understand both.
As Reito mentioned, Android saves
the state of the application in bundles.
You might have had the idea
that you would just save
all sorts of information in these bundles
and not have to worry about
any other form of persistence.
But, the thing is, these bundles go away
as soon as the user hits the Back key
in your main activity.
It's really important that they do this.
When the user chooses
to close your activity with the Back key,
the expectation is that next time
your activity is displayed,
it will be in the default state.
If the user backgrounds your app
using the Home key or the App Switcher,
the next time your activity is created,
it should resume from the current state.